monsieur chirac on se retrouve ce soir
il vous reste en quelque sorte 15 lille
peut convaincre maintenant tout de suite
ma première question je voudrais revenir
sur le débat notre soir avec françois
mitterrand et j'ai eu un peu
l'impression qu'ils vous avez fait le
coup du mépris du dédain et j'ai pas
compris pourquoi voulait pas relevé plus
brutalement d'avoir c'est dans sa nature
de faire le coup du mépris ensuite
venant de lui
cela ne ne perturbe pas enfin je
préférais le sait naturellement aux
téléspectateurs le soin de juger ce
n'est pas un argument de campagne que
d'afficher son mépris et vous croyez
qu'ils ont senti ainsi l'été sécateur je
n'en sais rien nous le verrons
probablement dimanche prochain si vous
zappez ostensiblement monsieur promu
nice pour marquer les gérants j'ai
entendu bien entendu mais la vérité
c'est que ce qui m'a paru très claire
dans ce débat et j'espère que cela a été
compris ainsi ces deux choses la
première c'est qu'il n'a vous l'aurez
observé rien proposé il s'est uniquement
référer au passé jusqu'à y compris la
loi falloux et la deuxième et qui m'a
beaucoup choqué et vous dire qui m'a
vraiment confirmé dans mon jugement que
sur ses capacités à assumer le destin de
notre pays dans une réflexion qu'il a
fait sur des échanges de vue que nous
avions eu en tête à tête il a travesti
la jeune assia gordji navires venant il
a travesti la vérité et ceci n'est
absolument pas acceptable
ça m'a donné à réfléchir sur beaucoup de
choses du passé de son passé il on n'a
pas le droit de dire de dire une contre
vérité aux français sur tout enfin je
veux dire avec un aplomb extraordinaire
devant quelqu'un qui sait parfaitement
qu'elle est à mourir de rire en nous
regardant dans les yeux non en évitant à
widnes on ne voyait pas il n'avait pas
voulu qu'il y ait de leur groupe mais en
évitant de me regarder dans les yeux et
ça vous savez ça m'a vraiment vous dire
choqué plus profond de moi même
alors après le coup du mépris il semble
actuellement il vous fasse le coup de la
honte à dire que en vous assimilant avec
les racines
enfin la plus l'impression que sur ce
terrain vous l'avez laissé la voie libre
et que vous êtes sûr de complexe à côté
je n'ai aucun complexe
d'abord parce que le président léopold
sédar senghor l'a rappelé récemment je
n'avais pas de preuve à donner dans ce
domaine en revanche ce que je voudrais
dire c'est que le courant protestataires
d'extrême droite auquel il se réfère
aujourd'hui mais c'est lui qui l'a créé
il n'existait pas en 80 unis la fera
danser dans sa représentation
parlementaire il n'existait pas elle
représentait 1 2% des voix
aujourd'hui 15 ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que le laxisme de la
politique de monsieur mitterrand pendant
cinq ans à créer les conditions
objectives de ce développement je crois
d'ailleurs qu'il y était favorable
alors là attention vous dites que il a
fait il à créer les conditions du
développement de d'un extrait de donner
à créer de bout en bout et il les a
créés probablement inconsciente
inconsciemment ou par incompétence mais
aussi volontairement pour créer une
perturbation c'est bien dans dans sa
manière de faire perturbations dans la
majorité et il a d'ailleurs parfaitement
réussi ensuite il a officialisé en
quelque sorte ce courant par la réforme
de la loi électorale et la
proportionnelle après il lui a donné
je dirais un coup de pouce en parlant du
vote des étrangers dont il ne parle plus
aujourd'hui mais qui permettait là
encore d'amplifier le courant dans
pierrick il ne l'a jamais proposé donc
j'ai un beau l'icm en hypocrite et
aujourd'hui il dit mais c'est moi le
pompier
le pompier pour éteindre et qu'elle fait
à feu que lui même a allumé alors est il
le mieux à même de maîtriser ces
phénomènes non risque que vous avez des
complexes à parler des valeurs allant
celle de ce pays d'abord je n'ai aucun
complexe
mais je voudrais dire deux choses la
première c'est que je ne me laisserai
pas englué dans un débat théorique sur
des valeurs alors que le
vrai problème que le candidat socialiste
veut éviter d'évoquer c'est le chômage
c'est l'identité nationale c'est
l'immigration c'est la pauvreté et le
moyen de lutter contre celle-ci c'est la
solidarité nationale c'est la protection
sociale c'est à dire la sécurité sociale
et le rétablissement de ses comptes
c'est les investissements de nos
entreprises pour qu'elles créent des
emplois et qu'elles soient compétitifs
demain en 1992 dans l'europe c'est la
préparation des grands équipements
français qui nous permettront de bien
être articulé sur les grands courants
d'échangés européens et de créer chez
nous la richesse c'est les moyens de
sauvegarder les intérêts des artisans
des commerçants des paysans des
industriels des professions libérales
dans les grands débats qui auront lieu
pour achever cette europe de 92 avec nos
partenaires
c'est ça les problèmes alors les débats
sur les valeurs monsieur mitterrand il
consacre l'essentiel de son propos
parce qu'il a peur d'eux du vrai débat
sur les problèmes les prés où il
dressait hier monsieur chirac en clair
que les socialistes monsieur mitterrand
cherche à escamoter les vrais débats en
utilisant ce faux débat sur les sur les
vraies valeurs pour une raison simple
c'est qu'ils ont toujours été incapable
et leurs bilans l'a bien montré de
d'apporter des réponses aux vrais
problèmes
alors ils s'ébattent dans les valeurs
mais sur les valeurs je dirais une
deuxième chose c'est que moi
j'appartiens à une famille la famille
gaulliste je suis étroitement et
fraternellement associé avec une autre
famille la famille centriste libéral
radical indépendante et nous sommes
ensemble porter depuis toujours d'un
certain nombre de convictions relatifs à
la sécurité qui conditionne la liberté
des hommes relatifs à la famille qui
conditionne la vie même de notre société
relatifs à la patrie et à l'engagement
qu'on doit avoir pour la défendre quoi
qu'il arrive dans toutes les
circonstances et que ce n'est
certainement pas le candidat socialiste
ou les socialistes qui me donneront à
cet égard des leçons ou des leçons de
morale
sur des valeurs qui ont toujours été les
miennes et je ne ne lui donnerait pas le
débat mais ce n'est pas ce débat qui est
en cause aujourd'hui entre nous le vrai
débat c'est comment répondre aux
problèmes des français et de la france
ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure et se
débat le candidat socialiste le fuit et
c'est ce que je lui reproche alors
changeons de sujet mais abordons un
sujet aussi dramatique aussi présent à
la pensée des français c'est la nouvelle
calédonie d'abord une interrogation
pourquoi est-ce que vous n'agissez pas
plus nettement pour libérer ces
malheureux gendarmes qui sont
actuellement emprisonnés dans des
conditions désastreuses
tout simplement parce qu'il s'agit d'une
prise d'otage un peu de la même nature
que celles auxquelles on a été confronté
dans le boeing récemment et que nous
devons faire en sorte naturellement de
ne pas mettre en danger la vie de nos
otages
mais ce que je peux vous dire et je ne
développerai pas plus ce thème ce soir
c'est que tout sera mis en oeuvre bien
sûr pour libérer nos otages mais surtout
pour libérer notre honneur c'est à dire
pour faire en sorte que les terroristes
soit déféré à la justice et répondent de
leurs actes
alors aller plus loin si vous me
permettez est ce que vous pourriez dire
ce soir que le fait que cette affaire
soit déclenchée quelques jours ou
quelques temps avant l'élection
présidentielle était un fait fortuit
c'est à dire se faire soit le fait du
hasard
naturellement pas les dirigeants
officiels du fln qu'est ce qui réduit à
sa plus stricte expression même dans le
milieu mélanésiens comme on l'a vu lors
des dernières élections présidentielle
régionales que monsieur mitterrand
essayer de faire annuler et que le
conseil constitutionnel a maintenu parce
qu'elle s'était déroulée parfaitement
normalement même le fn heynckes l'a
reconnu c'est d'une affaire préparée de
longue date depuis plusieurs mois pour
équiper cette grotte pour monter cette
opération pour bénéficier des
complicités extérieures et des aides
étrangères nécessaire j'aurais revenir
un peu sur monsieur mitterrand lui-même
avoue le critiquer sévèrement vous ne
pensez pas qu'il peut avoir changé et
que les hommes qui l'entourent peuvent
également avoir changé si j'écoute le
propos des hommes qui l'entourent
indépendamment des appels
je dois dire sans complexe qu'ils font
actuellement l égard des électeurs du
front national
et ce qui d'ailleurs les discrédite pour
me donner quelques leçons que ce soit
dans ce domaine car moi au moins je me
comporte avec dignité ce qui n'est pas
le cas d'un certain nombre des
collaborateurs du candidat socialiste
s'il a changé ou si l'on changé qu'il le
dise
mais si l'on change et en intégrant les
préoccupations des français en essayant
d'y répondre par les seuls moyens qui
ont fait leurs preuves à l'étranger en
europe ou en france pendant deux ans
alors je leur dis dans ce cas là vous
avez probablement intérêts à faire en
sorte que je puisse continuer à apporter
ses solutions
vous n'êtes probablement pas les mieux à
même de le faire mais nous ne savons pas
rien dans le propos de monsieur
mitterrand ne permet de dire si la
changer ou non l algérie c'est un chèque
en blanc qu'ils nous demandent dira
comment ça c'est de l'escroquerie
c'est de l'escroquerie mais comment
expliquez-vous que tu entres les
sandales bien entendu tant de français
s'apprêtent à voter pour lui le dimanche
sauf au dehors même des socialistes
il faudrait d'abord être sûr que les
sondages sont juste dit ce n'est pas ça
c'est sûr et il n'y en a pas eu depuis
une dizaine de jours ce n'est pas ce que
je ressent personnellement et moi j'ai
toujours fait confiance au bon sens des
français
je suis sûr que les français lorsqu'ils
auront à choisir c'est à dire a décidé
d'abord se souviendront de leur jugement
en mars 86 à l'égard de ce qu'avait été
monsieur mitterrand triomphant est
investi des pleins pouvoirs
qu'ils examineront d'un peu plus près ce
que avec bien des difficultés
j'ai fait avec ma majorité et qu'ils
réfléchiront à deux fois et par
conséquent je pense que l'espoir est
encore permis pour une france
rassemblant tous les hommes toutes les
femmes qui se reconnaissent dans les
vertus du dynamisme de la volonté de la
ténacité à développer notre pays à en
faire une terre où la justice sociale et
mieux affirmée et qui donc est capable
de créer les moyens pour cela
les français ont envie de tout ça je
crois que les français sont un peuple
henry dont 11 d'or joue monsieur
mitterrand c'est à dire je suis l'homme
qui calme qui fait qu tout va bien ça
c'est l'ambition de la médiocrité
c'est en quelque sorte le flou
l'immobilisme qui cache tout le reste y
compris la monture moi je suis sûr que
les français sont dans leur grande
majorité c'est cela que je veux
rassembler qu'ils soient de droite ou de
gauche
des hommes et des femmes dynamiques qui
se rendent parfaitement compte que nous
sommes confrontés à les vrais problèmes
qu'il faut lutter contre le chômage
contre la pauvreté qu'il faut développer
notre icône et notre économie créer les
richesses qui nous permettra d'être
dynamique et compétitif demain dans
l'europe et que pour cela il faut te une
direction qui rassemble ces différentes
valeurs je dirais arrivant à la fin de
la mission devrait poser une dernière
question qui va tout à fait dans le sens
de ce que vous venez de dire de quoi
parlera temps le 9 mai au matin
je pense que si je suis élu on parlera
immédiatement de l'action qui doit être
engagée pour répondre à ces
préoccupations qu'on évoquait tout à
l'heure et qui sont celles des français
si le candidat socialiste est élu on
parlera naturellement d'abord des
combines politiques
et puis on s'apercevra qu'elle ne marche
pas parce que nous ne sommes plus sous
la quatrième république
et alors on parlera de l'élection
législative
mais ceci me conduite à une dernière
appréciation que j'ai évoquées hier soir
et que j'évoquerai encore ce soir
si vous vous reconnaissez dans ce café
le candidat socialiste pendant cinq ans
et dans ce qu'il dit aujourd'hui alors
il faut voter pour lui si vous
considérez que l'effort engagé pour le
redressement de notre pays par mon
gouvernement c'est-à-dire par moi même
soutenu par ma majorité qui me permet
immédiatement d'engager à nouveau
l'action gouvernementale alors il faut
voter pour moi mais si vous êtes des
hommes et des femmes responsables
rappelez vous qu'il faut voter qu'on ne
peut pas s'abstenir et que de toute
façon
s'abstenir c'est en réalité
mathématiquement voter pour monsieur
mitterrand alors je vous fais confiance